let's do some more practice word
problems patricia is building a sandbox
for her daughter it is to be five feet
wide and eight feet long so let me draw
that so the five feet wide it is to be
five feet wide so there you go that's
five feet right there and eight feet
long i'll do that in orange eight feet
long so this is like if we're looking
down on the sandbox eight feet long
eight feet long so the sandbox if we're
looking down on it would look something
like that that would be five feet and
then this side over here would also be
eight feet all right she wants the
height of the sandbox to be four inches
above the height of the sand okay so if
we were to draw the sandbox like this
so if we were to draw and draw three so
that's eight
that is
that distance right there is five feet
and then
there is some height which i think we're
going to have to figure out
so let me draw the whole box just like
that
and just
like
that the sand is going to fill a certain
amount of the sandbox
so the sand is going to fill
maybe until right over there so that's
how much the sand is going to fill of
the sandbox so all of that is sand and
she wants the height of the sandbox to
be four inches above the height of the
sand so she wants this distance right
here the amount that the height goes
above the sand itself to be four
four inches or a third of a foot
depending how you want to think about it
now she has 30 cubic feet of sand she
has 30 cubic feet of sand so this sand
right here is 30
feet
cubed how high should the sandbox be
so this information right here the
volume of the sand tells us we using it
we can figure out how high the level of
the sand will be because the let's view
it this way
let's call
let's call l let's call l or we just use
x let's say x is the height of the sand
x is equal to height
of
sand
so the total volume of our sand is going
to be the height of the sand times the
length of the box times eight
times the width of the box times five
and this is going to be the total volume
which they told us is 30 cubic feet
it is 30
cubic feet we're taking x feet times 8
feet times 5 feet so we'll get 30 feet
cubed if we were to keep track of the
units so what is this 8 times 5 is 40 8
times 5 is 40. so we get 40x is equal to
30. if we divide both sides by 40
both sides of the equation by 40 let me
do that you divide both sides by 40 you
get x is equal to that just becomes an x
x is equal to 30 over 40 or it equals 3
it equals 3 4 of a foot so this right
here
this right here is going to be 3 4 of a
foot now what is three-fourths of a foot
we know let's see three-fourths of a
foot
we know that there are
we know that there are 12
inches
per foot
the feet cancel out 12 times 3 over 4 is
what you can divide 12 by 4 and get a 3.
divide the 4 by 4 and get a 1 you get 3
by times 3 this is 9 inches
nine inches so the height of the sand
right there is nine
inches
now she wants the height of the sandbox
to be four inches above the height of
the sand so this is nine inches she
wants four more inches so what she wants
the height of the sandbox
height of sandbox it should be the 9
inches of the height of the sand plus 4
which is equal to 13
inches
and we
are
done let's do the next problem
it was a sale day
in macy's and everything was 20 percent
less than the regular price peter bought
a pair of shoes and using a coupon got
an additional he got an additional 10
let me do that a different color he got
an additional 10
off the discounted price the price he
paid was 36 dollars the price he paid
for the shoes do that in a different
color
the price he paid
for the shoes was 36 how much did it
originally cost
so let's just use so x is equal to
original
original
cost
so there was just a regular sale on that
day everything was 20 percent less than
the regular price
so using that information on that day if
you wanted to buy the shoes the cost of
the shoes would be x minus 0.20 x or
0.20
x
which is equal to
0.8
x right if you have 20 off of a price
you're going to be paying 80 percent of
the original price so this is the price
that everyone would have paid without a
coupon and that's what that line is
telling us right there
now peter got a
pair of shoes and using a coupon got an
additional 10 off of this an additional
10
off of that
so he's paying 10 less than this or
another way to think of it is he only
had to pay 90 percent of this price
right if you take
if you take 0.8 x and from that you
subtract 10 percent of this
so from that you subtract 10 percent
of that of
0.8
x
right this is the same thing right this
is a 1 times 0.8 x
this is the same thing as 1 minus 0.1 so
this is the same thing this is equal to
90
of
0.8 x
of
0.8
x and it might actually be very natural
for you to go straight to this it's
natural for me if i'm paying 20 less
than the regular price that means i'm
going to pay 80 percent of the regular
price and if i get an additional 10
off of that that means i'm only going to
pay 90
of that so this is what he's going to
pay and would they tell us that that
price is 36.
that price is equal to
36
dollars so if we want to figure out x
well we can multiply 0.9 times 0.8 let's
do that so
0.9 times 0.8 nine times eight is
seventy-two we have two numbers behind
the decimal one two so it's 0.72 so you
get 0.72
x is equal to
36
or maybe we could say 72 over 100
72 over 100
x is equal to 36 or we could even say
this is the same thing as what is it
that's the same thing as 36 over 50
right
36
over 50 x is equal to 36 and this isn't
even in lowest common forms i could keep
i could this is the same thing as 18
over 25 but i like this number because
it i have a 36 here and so i can
multiply both sides by the inverse of
this 50
over 36 times this i have to do it to
both sides of the equation 50 over 36
36s cancel out 50s cancel out
36s cancel out and you're left with x is
equal to
fifty dollars the shoes originally cost
fifty dollars
next question
rosa has saved
all year and wishes to spend the money
she has on new clothes
and a vacation
she will spend 30 percent more on the
vacation than on the clothes so let's
say let's see that c is
amount
spent
on
clothes
she's going to spend 30 more on the
vacation
so let's say v is equal to the amount
spent
on
vacation
well they just told us that the vacation
she's going to spend 30 more than on the
clothes so the vacation is going to be
equal to the amount she spends on the
clothes plus
30 percent
of the amount she spends on the clothes
and this is the same thing as 1.3
1.3 times the amount she spends on the
clothes that's how much she's going to
spend on the vacation
now
if she saved a thousand in total how
much money to the nearest whole dollar
can she spend on the vacation so between
v and c she can only spend a thousand
dollars
so
v vacation plus her clothes can only be
one
thousand
dollars and so we know what the vacation
is in terms of the clothes we can do a
little substitution the vacation is
going to be 1.3 times the clothes so we
can substitute there so you have 1.3
times the clothes that's the vacation
expenditure
plus the amount she spends on the
clothes is equal to 1 000.
this is 1.3 plus 1 is 2.3
times the amount of clothes is on the
amount she spends on clothes will be
equal to 1 000. divide both sides by 2.3
i'll get the calculator out for this one
so we have 1
000 divided by 2.3
is equal to
434 dollars and 78 cents
so c is equal to i already forgot the
number 434.78
434
and 78 dollars so that's the amount she
spends on clothes the rest of her money
is going to be spent on a vacation so
her vacation is going to be at 1 000
minus this so her vacation expenditure
is going to be 1 000
minus 434.78
do the calculator for this one so let's
see let's make this into a negative
number and then let's add
1000 to it
and we get
22
565.22
so
565 dollars and 22 cents and i'll leave
it up to you to check it this this is
how much she spends on the vacation
these add up to a thousand dollars and
this should be exactly 30 more than this
amount the amount she spends on her
clothes